其他人：到别墅来了
Others: It came to the villa
其他人：好好可爱
Others: So cute
Alice: 更喜欢猫还是狗
Alice: Do you like cats or dogs more?
其他人：这不好说我一开始喜欢猫最近是狗派
Others: It's hard to say, I liked cats at first, but recently I'm into dogs
Alice: 哦快快快快看
Alice: Oh, quick, quick, quick, look!
Jake: 拍一个跟他们斗舞
Jake: Let's film a dance battle with them.
Jake: 跟他们斗舞
Jake: Dance battle with them.
Jake: 斗是什么
Jake: What is "battle"?
Lucia: 好厉害啊
Lucia: So cool!
Tasha: 就是有一个棍子拼控制另一根棍子
Tasha: It's like using one stick to control another stick.
Alice: 能玩一下吗
Alice: Can we try it?
其他人：哎你好这个叫什么啊
Others: Hey, what's this called?
其他人：这叫花棍
Others: This is called "flower stick".
Alice: 花棍
Alice: Flower stick.
Jake: 花棍
Jake: Flower stick.
Alice: 其他人：
Alice: Others:
Jake: 像是那种打打扫厕所呵
Jake: It's like cleaning a toilet, haha.
Jake: 这练多久啊
Jake: How long have you practiced?
Jake: 能能练这样
Jake: To be able to do this?
其他人： 您练快
Others: You practice quickly.
其他人：有个十天半月的
Others: About ten days to half a month.
Jake: 半个月半个月就会玩了
Jake: Half a month and you can play it.
其他人： 对像你们这样快
Others: Yes, for quick learners like you.
其他人：我们上岁数的就慢了
Others: For us older folks, it takes longer.
Alice: 我们能试一下吗
Alice: Can we give it a try?
其他人：能可以
Others: Sure, go ahead.
Jake: 哈哈谢谢您
Jake: Haha, thank you.
Alice: 谢谢怎怎怎么发力呢
Alice: Thank you. How do you exert force?
其他人：发力这个这个
Others: Exert force like this.
Jake: 要要要不哎
Jake: Should I... hey.
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Ouch, oh no.
Jake:绕了3圈挺厉害
Jake: Haha, it spun three times, pretty good.
Alice:哈哈
Alice:这是
Alice: 我发现转不起来
Alice: I can't make it spin.
Alice: 我能看下你是怎么开始的吗
Alice: Can I see how you start it?
其他人：可以这这不这不是拿下来都会
Others: Sure, this isn't something you just pick up and do.
其他人：你就得练
Others: You have to practice.
其他人：你要是想练这个
Others: If you want to get good at this,
其他人：就是从这个基础学起
Others: you need to start with the basics.
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 这样写来的
Alice: That's how you do it.
其他人：掌握这个平衡
Others: Just balance it.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Shure:  你给我拿一下我试一下
Shure: Let me hold it, I'll give it a try.
Tasha: 迫不及待哦
Tasha: Can't wait!
Alice: 哦这样起来的
Alice: Oh, it came up like this.
Alice: 哦哦行
Alice: Oh, oh, okay.
Alice: 太牛了
Alice: Amazing!
其他人：这这样调
Others: Adjust it like this.
其他人：能调你就调
Others: Adjust it if you can.
其他人：偏过中心就行
Others: Just past the center.
其他人：偏过中心
Others: Past the center.
Alice: 我能使两个棍弄起来吗
Alice: Can I use two sticks?
Jake: 你厉害
Jake: You're awesome.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
其他人：不要抓这毛
Others: Don't grab this hair.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 这毛
Jake: This hair.
其他人： 这就跟头发一样
Others: It's just like hair.
Jake: 这自怎么自己做的
Jake: Did you make this yourself?
Jake: 外边买
Jake: Bought it outside.
Alice: 我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Jake: 哦哦哦也卖哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, it's for sale too.
Alice: 谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Jake: 要不咱两个扔试试
Jake: Why don't we both try throwing?
Jake: 哎呦厉害
Jake: Oh, amazing.
其他人： 两个的比一个的难度大多了
Others: Two are much harder than one.
Tasha: 差多了
Tasha: Much harder.
其他人： 因为是一个左手一个右手
Others: Because it's one in the left hand and one in the right hand.
Jake: 这两个棍
Jake: These two sticks.
Jake: 两两两个棍两个棍
Jake: Two, two sticks, two sticks.
Jake: 两个棍容易一点
Jake: Two sticks are a bit easier.
其他人： 这你也就看看热闹你如果想学这个从这个基础学起
Others: You're just watching for fun. If you want to learn, start from the basics.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yay.
Jake: 转起来了
Jake: It's spinning.
Jake: 就刚刚刚刚那一段
Jake: Just that part earlier.
Jake: 然后就重复剪出来
Jake: Then just keep repeating and edit it out.
Jake: 重复你就一直转
Jake: Repeat and keep spinning.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈GIF出来了
Jake: Hahaha, make it into a GIF.
Jake: 哦可以
Jake: Oh, that's good.
Jake: 够剪了够剪了够剪了
Jake: Enough to edit, enough to edit.
Jake: 谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Katrina:  走吧下一个景
Katrina: Let's go to the next scene.
Jake: 走吧下一个
Jake: Let's go to the next one.
Jake: 我们最后转到原来的位置
Jake: We'll finally return to the original spot.
Jake: 这样整个公园就呈现出来了
Jake: This way, the whole park will be showcased.
Alice: 啊差不多就围湖一圈
Alice: Ah, almost like circling around the lake.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 不大
Alice: It's not big.
Alice: 这个小亭子还挺凉快的通风
Alice: This little pavilion is quite cool and breezy.
Jake: 对这亭子挺好
Jake: Yeah, this pavilion is nice.
Alice: 噢那个那个上面黏黏的
Alice: Oh, that thing on top is sticky.
Alice: 他就增加那个粘性
Alice: It just adds that stickiness.
Lucia: 啊摩擦摩擦力吗
Lucia: Ah, you mean friction?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 嗯就那个皮上面有那个黏黏的油
Alice: Yeah, there's this sticky oil on the surface.
Jake: 哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Jake: 妙啊
Jake: Brilliant.
Alice: 搓一下吧
Alice: Rub it a bit.
Jake: 湖水洗一洗
Jake: Wash it in the lake water.
Alice: 太太臭了哈哈
Alice: It's too smelly, haha.
Shure: 还好有这个事顶一下要不然就被骂了
Shure: Good thing this happened, otherwise we would've been scolded.
Shure: 不然话就会被骂
Shure: Otherwise, we would've been yelled at.
Katrina:  也可以往里走哎
Katrina: We can also walk inside, hey.
Alice: 禁止钓鱼
Alice: No fishing allowed.
Katrina:  怎么会这么多鱼啊
Katrina: Why are there so many fish?
Katrina:  感觉这水质不是特别好
Katrina: The water quality doesn't seem that good.
Shure:  水却清澈无鱼
Shure: Clear water has no fish.
Lucia: 啊没有
Lucia: Ah, no.
Lucia: 我乱说的
Lucia: I was just making that up.
Katrina:  外面走走看
Katrina: Let's walk outside and see.
Shure:  就是这吧
Shure: This is it.
Lucia: 或许地理课上吗
Lucia: Maybe during geography class?
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: Could be.
Jake: 可以绕啊
Jake: We can circle around.
Jake: 只要绕过去就行
Jake: As long as we go around, it's fine.
Shure:  你带了头盔
Shure: You brought a helmet.
Shure:  可是没有插上
Shure: But it's not plugged in.
Jake: 一会再插
Jake: We'll plug it in later.
Jake: 刚刚其实应该插一下
Jake: Actually, we should have plugged it in just now.
Jake: 他一次只能录25分钟
Jake: It can only record for 25 minutes at a time.
Jake: 我要找到25分钟的那个时间段
Jake: I need to find the 25-minute mark.
Jake: 刚刚那段其实挺好的忘了
Jake: That part just now was great, but I forgot.
Jake: 看下一段
Jake: Let's watch the next segment.
Alice: 这颜色好漂亮
Alice: This color is so beautiful.
Alice: 红的
Alice: It's red.
Tasha: 这个树吗
Tasha: Is it this tree?
Alice: 对呀
Alice: Yes.
Tasha: 鸡爪7哦
Tasha: Chicken feet 7, huh?
Alice: 好漂亮好漂亮
Alice: So beautiful, so beautiful.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 叫什么呀
Jake: What's it called?
Tasha: 爪7
Tasha: Claw 7.
Tasha: 是的他长得像鸡爪子一样
Tasha: Yes, it looks like chicken claws.
Jake: 好想吃啊
Jake: I really want to eat it.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 也想吃
Jake: I also want to eat it.
Tasha: 那我给你摘一片你吃吧
Tasha: Then I'll pick a piece for you to eat.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我还以为打开方式是
Lucia: I thought the way to open it was...
Lucia: 我们晚上吃鸡爪呢
Lucia: We're eating chicken feet tonight.
Jake: 呵呵是这个意思
Jake: Haha, that's what it means.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 呵呵来给我试叶子可能是
Jake: Haha, come on, give me a leaf to try, maybe it’s...
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one.
Shure:  我说我说这里面有蛤蟆啊叫了
Shure: I say, I say, there's a toad calling in here.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure:  听到了蟾蜍的叫声
Shure: I heard the sound of a toad.
Shure:  稍微践踏一下
Shure: Slightly trample it.
Jake: 找手串呢
Jake: Looking for the bead string.
Shure:  我听到了
Shure: I heard it.
Jake: 找蛤蟆了
Jake: Looking for the toad.
Shure:  哈哈蛤蟆听取蛙声一片
Shure: Haha, the toad listening to the frogs' chorus.
Alice: 想从这走过去
Alice: Want to walk through from here.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 比谁走得快
Jake: Let's see who walks faster.
Jake: 到那个呃真的走
Jake: To that... really walk.
Lucia: 不行底下都有水
Lucia: No, there's water underneath.
Lucia: 没有落脚点
Lucia: There's no place to step.
Tasha: 很滑的
Tasha: It's really slippery.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 掉进去了的话
Lucia: If you fall in...
Jake: 这个
Jake: This...
Lucia: AI就会捕获人类早期落水宝贵纪录
Lucia: AI will capture valuable early records of humans falling into the water.
Alice: 水好
Alice: The water is nice.
Jake: 是这是他捕捉的最后一个信号
Jake: Yes, this is the last signal it captured.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哦然后进水就坏了是吗
Lucia: Oh, and then it breaks when water gets in, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Alice: AI能不能理解我们为什么非要从这走
Alice: Can AI understand why we insist on going this way?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 他就最后总结出人类都太不理性了
Lucia: In the end, it concludes that humans are too irrational.
Lucia: 然后决定消灭人类吗
Lucia: And then decides to eliminate humans?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 我看了好多类似的科幻片哈哈
Lucia: I've watched a lot of sci-fi movies like this, haha.
Jake: 哦是吧
Jake: Oh, really?
其他人：桃花潭水深千尺
Others: The water of Peach Blossom Pond is a thousand feet deep.
Shure:  前面这条是京杭大运河
Shure: The canal ahead is the Grand Canal.
Jake: 哪一条啊
Jake: Which one?
Tasha: 真的吗潜在的这条河
Tasha: Really? This potential river?
Tasha: 我们就可以回家了阿sir
Tasha: We can go home, officer.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake: 那你的那个手链在杭州可以能找到
Jake: Then you might find that bracelet in Hangzhou.
Shure:  可以哈哈哈
Shure: Maybe, haha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Shure:  你怎么知道我过一段要去杭州
Shure: How did you know I was planning to go to Hangzhou later?
Jake: 那你去找找
Jake: Then you should look for it.
Shure:  发现前面就是京杭大运河
Shure: I found out the canal ahead is the Grand Canal.
Shure:  我们在杭州
Shure: We're in Hangzhou.
Shure:  是不是能绕上去
Shure: Can we go around it?
Jake: 先录一段
Jake: Let's record a segment first.
Alice: 晚上在这应该挺舒服的
Alice: It should be quite nice here at night.
Alice: 没事
Alice: 我说晚上逛公园很舒服
Alice: 丁香
Alice: Lilacs.
Jake: 贴了一个符就防虫了上面
Jake: Stick a charm on it to prevent bugs.
Tasha: 无法从吊带上下来
Tasha: Can't get down from the strap.
Jake: 哦这么好这
Jake: Oh, this is so nice.
Tasha: 然后就死在树上
Tasha: And then died on the tree.
Tasha: 当然你相信了吗
Tasha: Of course, do you believe it?
Jake: 我信
Jake: I believe it.
Tasha: 这棵树好恶心呀
Tasha: This tree is so gross.
Alice: 啥呀
Alice: What?
Tasha: 我说这个树好恶心啊
Tasha: I said this tree is so gross.
Alice: 麻麻赖赖的
Alice: It's all slimy.
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake: 一个墓地
Jake: A cemetery.
Jake: 虽然不知道是谁
Jake: Though I don't know who it is.
Alice: 谁埋这啊
Alice: Who is buried here?
Jake: 墓地
Jake: A cemetery.
Tasha: 墓地
Tasha: A cemetery.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Alice: 这有个坟包
Alice: There's a grave mound here.
Tasha: 哦天呐
Tasha: Oh my god.
Alice: 这公园是不是就是为他建的
Alice: Is this park built for him?
Tasha: 李治好像
Tasha: Maybe Li Zhi.
Jake: 不止吧刚刚好像看到别
Jake: Not just him, I think I saw others.
Jake: 的目的好像是
Jake: There are other graves too.
Alice: 原来是个大墓园啊
Alice: So it's a big cemetery.
Jake: 嗯哼可以是或者是原来有一个公园
Jake: Yeah, maybe it was a park before.
Jake: 然后谁想埋着埋一下
Jake: And then people started burying here.
Jake: 住附近的埋一下
Jake: People living nearby.
Alice: 这是海棠吧
Alice: Is this a crabapple tree?
Tasha: 嗯是的吧
Tasha: Yeah, probably.
Alice: 像海棠海棠啊
Alice: Looks like a crabapple tree.
Alice: 已经过了观赏季了
Alice: The blooming season is over.
Alice: 走吧
Alice: 最多看看郁金香估计就
Alice: We might see some tulips.
Tasha: 哪有郁金香
Tasha: Where are the tulips?
Alice: 我说这个季节
Alice: I mean this season.
Alice:芍药牡丹之类的
Alice: Peonies and such.
Shure:  向我徐徐走过来
Shure: Walking slowly towards me.
Shure:  你好害怕
Shure: So scared.
Shure:  你好可怕呀
Shure: So terrifying.
Shure:  你这个就是就是就是
Shure: You are just, just, just.
Jake: 为啥呀我这一棒槌下去是吧
Jake: Why? If I hit you with this, right?
Shure:  一脸严肃
Shure: With a serious face.
Shure:  然后肩膀就这样走回
Shure: Then just walk back with your shoulders like this.
Shure:  我爬山
Shure: I'm climbing a mountain.
Jake: 来爬山这是什么山
Jake: What mountain are we climbing?
Alice: 未名山
Alice: Unnamed Mountain.
Lucia: 陡坡路华山
Lucia: Steep Slope Huashan.
Katrina:  情人坡
Katrina: Lover's Slope.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 不知道是哪几个字有诗意的呢哈哈
Lucia: I wonder which poetic characters it has, haha.
Jake: 是是是一个华山
Jake: Yes, it's a Huashan.
Jake: 简称华山
Jake: It's called Huashan for short.
Jake: 我们在爬华山
Jake: We're climbing Huashan.
Katrina:  哇原来长这样
Katrina: Wow, so this is what it looks like.
Jake: 香山哈哈哈哈嘿
Jake: Xiangshan, hahaha, hey.
Shure:  当你走近脱下爱心般的目光
Shure: When you get closer, take off your loving gaze.
Katrina:  没见过紫丁香
Katrina: Never seen lilacs.
Katrina:  那白的呢
Katrina: What about the white ones?
Alice: 白丁香
Alice: White top lilac.
Katrina:  白丁香
Katrina: White lilac.
Katrina:  转弯
Katrina: Turn here.
Jake: 这怎么有个小洞
Jake: Why is there a small hole here?
Shure:  AI会不会以为我们刚刚又回去了
Shure: Will AI think we just went back again?
Jake: 这到公路了
Jake: We've reached the road.
Jake: 能开车了
Jake: We can drive now.
Jake: 这是出园了吗
Jake: Are we out of the park?
Jake: 这小台阶挺好
Jake: These small steps are nice.
Alice: 到梯田
Shure: 这什么塔
Shure: What tower is this?
Alice: 雷峰塔
Alice: Leifeng Pagoda.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  胡说八道
Katrina: Nonsense.
Katrina:  张口就来
Katrina: Making things up.
Jake: 可以过去吧
Jake: Can we go over there?
Jake: 问问问
Jake: Ask, ask.
Jake: 问看看
Jake: Ask and see.
Jake: 这有个地图倒是可以看看
Jake: There's a map here, we can take a look.
Jake: 哎咱在哪啊
Jake: Hey, where are we?
Alice: 您的位置
Alice: Your location.
Jake: 在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Alice:它也不显示吗
Lucia: 这个有一个小星号的地方
Lucia: It's the place with the little star.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This
Alice:我们在这
Lucia: 您在这里
Lucia: You're here
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
其他人：好热啊
Others: It's so hot
其他人：我再遇到一个售货机我一定要买那个投币饮料
Others: If I see another vending machine, I must buy that coin-operated drink
其他人：我刚刚路过一个就看到了好想买
Others: I just passed one and really wanted to buy it
Tasha: 我刚刚想买但你们都走远了
Tasha: I wanted to buy it just now but you all walked too far ahead
其他人： 就是售货机里有一个饮料
Others: There's a drink in the vending machine
其他人：我还挺想买的哦哦哦
Others: I really want to buy it, oh oh oh
Tasha: 我刚刚看你想买你们都走了
Tasha: I saw you wanted to buy it but you all left
Tasha: 然后我在那
Tasha: And then I was there
Jake: 哦售货机
Jake: Oh, the vending machine
其他人：下次再遇到我就买
Others: Next time I see it, I'll buy it
Jake: 好一会转
Jake: Okay, let's turn
Jake: 转到最后的这个地方
Jake: Turn to the last place
Jake: 然后再多走一段
Jake: Then walk a bit more
Katrina:  什么饮料
Katrina: What drink?
Shure:  我只想要瓶水
Shure: I just want a bottle of water
Shure:  自己的生日
Shure: It's my birthday
Tasha: 那个桃子饮料汁
Tasha: That peach drink
Tasha: 我当时在想他是冰的还是常温的
Tasha: I was wondering if it was cold or room temperature
Jake: 游
Jake: Tour
Jake: 游客中心是吗
Jake: Tourist center, right?
Tasha: 冰的还是常温的
Tasha: Cold or room temperature
Jake: 还是会有卖的
Jake: There should still be some for sale
Tasha: 然后我就在那等了半天
Tasha: Then I waited there for a long time
Tasha: 然后我开始人脸识别发现识别不上啊
Tasha: Then I tried face recognition but it didn't work
Jake: 卖水的地方
Jake: The place selling water
Katrina:  刚进来的地方
Katrina: The place we just entered
Tasha: 然后开始拿支付宝
Tasha: Then I started using Alipay
Lucia: 他们说是一个
Lucia: They said it's a
Lucia: 那个自动售货机
Lucia: That vending machine
Tasha: 我发现你们已经走了
Tasha: I found you guys had already left
Katrina:  你在哪呢
Katrina: Where are you?
其他人：牡丹台
Others: Peony Terrace
Katrina:  刚刚进来的地方
Katrina: The place we just entered
Katrina:  从这进来的吧
Katrina: We came in from here, right?
Katrina:  这样绕一圈
Katrina: Walk around like this
Katrina:  还是这这吧
Katrina: Or maybe this way
Jake: 可能是西边
Jake: It might be to the west
Jake: 这边像这边像一点
Jake: Over here, a bit more this way.
Katrina:  一边进来
Katrina: Come in from one side.
Katrina:  哦我知道了
Katrina: Oh, I got it.
Katrina:  是一个是这样
Katrina: It's like this.
Katrina:  我们是这样子过来的
Katrina: We came over this way.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Katrina:  嗯就是从这
Katrina: Yeah, from here.
Katrina:  那我们转一会就进去了
Katrina: Then we turn for a bit and go in.
Katrina:  差不多在这个位置
Katrina: It's roughly in this spot.
Lucia: 所以这俩确实是一个公园
Lucia: So, these two are actually one park.
Lucia: 只不过有一个北关大道
Lucia: It's just that North Gate Avenue separates them.
Lucia: 把他们俩隔开了
Lucia: Divides them.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Right, right.
Katrina:  那能出去吗
Katrina: Can we go out there?
Jake: 这出去是这是吗
Jake: This way out, right?
Jake: 这是啥玩意
Jake: What's this thing?
Jake: 啥也不是
Jake: It's nothing.
Jake: 20号是谁
Jake: Who's number 20?
Alice:堤路
Alice: Tilu.
Jake: 南站道北站道
Jake: South Station Road, North Station Road.
Jake: 再转回去买水走
Jake: Let's circle back and buy some water.
Tasha: 服从
Tasha: Understood.
Katrina:  let's go
Katrina: Let's go.
Tasha: 走开这里是蝴蝶的盛宴哈哈哈
Tasha: Move away, this is the butterfly feast, haha.
Jake: 我们去买水吧
Jake: Let's go buy some water.
Tasha: 好呀
Tasha: Sure.
Jake: 买到就是绕到入口的地方
Jake: Once we get it, we'll go back to the entrance.
Tasha: 刚刚你们没看到我的那个地方
Tasha: You guys didn't see my place earlier.
Lucia: 蝴蝶又补气哈哈哈
Lucia: The butterflies are boosting, haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈蝴蝶应该怎么抓呀
Jake: Hahaha, how do you catch butterflies?
Jake: 拿网抓是吧
Jake: With a net, right?
Lucia: 啊没有
Lucia: No, no.
Jake: 没有我现在
Jake: I don't have one now.
Lucia: 我们是在说怎么形容
Lucia: We're talking about how to describe it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈这个是蝴蝶诱捕器
Jake: Hahaha, this is a butterfly trap.
Jake: 你们就过来了是吧
Jake: You guys came over, right?
Tasha: 哈哈好
Tasha: Haha, yeah.
Alice: 葫芦湖
Alice: Gourd Lake.
Jake: 走吧我们绕回去
Jake: Let's go, we'll circle back.
Tasha: 今天怎么不穿绿色
Tasha: Why aren't you wearing green today?
Tasha: 你已经被踢出我们蝴蝶工会了
Tasha: You've already been kicked out of our Butterfly Guild.
Lucia: 哦这样啊
Lucia: Oh, really?
Tasha: 哈哈哈我还有我还有一个护士
Tasha: Hahaha, I still have, I still have a nurse.
Jake: 我还有我还有一个裤子是绿色
Jake: I still have, I still have a pair of green pants.
Lucia: 今天好像没
Lucia: Seems like not today.
Lucia: 这次出来好像没带绿衣服
Lucia: Seems like I didn't bring any green clothes this time.
Lucia: 早知道应该带一条绿裙子
Lucia: I should've brought a green dress.
Jake: 蝴蝶有绿色的吗
Jake: Do butterflies even have green?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Jake: 嗯好像不太有
Jake: Hmm, seems like not really.
Lucia: 好像不太有
Lucia: Seems like not really.
Tasha: 是那个穿着一身绿裙子啊
Tasha: It's the one wearing a green dress, right?
Jake: 精品蝴蝶
Jake: Premium Butterfly.
Lucia: 对对那个小人是绿色的
Lucia: Yes, yes, that little character is green.
Lucia: 小人身边那蝴蝶好像也还真是绿色的
Lucia: The butterfly next to the little character is also actually green.
其他人：是的
Everyone: Yes.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 官方好像每个人格都给出来三个形象
Alice: The official seems to have given three personas for each character.
其他人：哦对一个男的一个女的嗯还有
Everyone: Oh yes, one male, one female, and...
Tasha: 还有个什么
Tasha: What's the other one?
Alice: 不知道但是呃
Lucia: 还有一个中性形象就是
Lucia: And one neutral persona, that is...
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 还有男蝴蝶
Tasha: There's also a male butterfly.
Tasha: 就是跟我们穿的是不一样的是吧对
Tasha: It's different from what we're wearing, right?
Alice: 啊是的
Alice: Ah, yes.
Lucia: 对就是他的形象会有变化
Lucia: Yes, the image will change.
Lucia: 但是代表的都是这个人格
Lucia: But they all represent this persona.
Alice: 就平时看见EFP竟然是个女的形象
Alice: Normally, you see EFP as a female persona.
Alice: 我一直以为是个
Alice: I always thought it was...
Alice: 像不像男孩
Alice: Doesn't it look like a boy?
Lucia: 哦这样啊
Lucia: Oh, really?
Alice: 就快乐小狗好像是女的
Alice: The Happy Puppy seems to be female.
Alice: 就给出来的
Alice: The one given.
Alice: 比较通用的
Alice: More universal.
Tasha: 那那你的快乐小狗是男的吗
Tasha: So, is your Happy Puppy male?
Jake: 啊这个也分吗
Jake: Ah, does that matter?
Alice: 就是官方是给出来三个形象的
Alice: The official gave three personas.
Alice: 一般只就是我们平时用的只
Alice: Usually, we just use...
Jake: 哦还有
Jake: Oh, and also
Alice: 一个是典型的形象
Alice: One is a typical image
Jake: 型的形象
Jake: Typical image
Lucia: 呃不是NTP
Lucia: Uh, not NTP
Lucia: 是药水是做实验的那个
Lucia: It's the potion used for experiments
Alice: PG是小老头
Alice: PG is the little old man
Lucia: 啊对对
Lucia: Ah, right, right
Katrina:  前两天测MB
Katrina: I tested MB the other day
Katrina:  赛发现我变成s人了
Katrina: and found out I turned into an S
Alice: ESTJ是尺节尺子
Alice: ESTJ is like a ruler
Lucia: ESTJ我朋友里好像都没有ESTJ
Lucia: I don't think any of my friends are ESTJ
Katrina:  他上次不是说没有s吗
Katrina: Didn't he say last time there was no S?
Katrina:  因为因为我是这两天才变成了s
Katrina: Because, I just turned into an S these past few days
Katrina:  不知道为什么变成
Katrina: No idea why I turned
Katrina:  我本来是ENT
Katrina: I used to be ENT
Katrina:  那就是唯一一个s人了是不是
Katrina: So I'm the only S now, right?
Jake: 啊你怎么突然变成了s
Jake: Ah, how did you suddenly turn into an S?
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: No
Katrina:  就是好像在就是来北京前一天测的
Katrina: I think I tested it the day before I came to Beijing
Jake: 来北京突然变异了
Jake: Came to Beijing and suddenly mutated
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake: 果然是变异
Jake: Definitely mutated
Lucia: 你看为什么大家加入你的team都会变
Lucia: See, why does everyone join your team and change?
Jake: 一直在变异
Jake: Constantly mutating
Jake: 好吃的吗
Jake: Is it tasty?
Lucia: 就是本来你说紫藤和那个谢斌竹
Lucia: Originally, you said both Wisteria and Xie Binzhu
Lucia: 都是换了
Lucia: Both changed
Lucia: 换了发型
Lucia: Changed their hairstyles
Jake: 噢真的吗
Jake: Oh really?
Lucia: 然后然后现在那个
Lucia: And then now that
Jake: 噢OK OK OK
Jake: Oh OK OK OK
Lucia: 哈哈又有人从n变成了s
Lucia: Haha, someone else went from N to S
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Katrina:  对我刚开始没嗯
Katrina: Yeah, at first I didn't
Lucia: 雨轩真的从n变成了s吗
Lucia: Did Yuxuan really go from N to S?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake: 你们有一个人从屁变成借我导致
Jake: One of you went from P to borrow me, causing
Jake: 能理解哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: I can understand, hahaha
Lucia: 实话说我这两天已经有点想要变成g
Lucia: Honestly, I've been feeling like turning into a G these past two days
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Tasha: 因为整个组织的无纪律性
Tasha: Because of the lack of discipline in the whole organization.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 不过也挺好的
Lucia: But it's pretty good.
Lucia: 我喜欢一些随机事件发生
Lucia: I like when some random events happen.
Lucia: 就本质上还是很p
Lucia: It’s just essentially very p.
Jake: 这个太这个太P了
Jake: This is too p.
Jake: 这个太p了
Katrina:  搁哪呢
Katrina: Where is it?
Katrina:  这能这能过去吗
Katrina: Can we get through here?
Lucia: 我觉得我大部分的朋友都是NP
Lucia: I think most of my friends are NP.
Alice: 确实
Alice: True.
Lucia: 也有这一人
Lucia: There’s also this one person.
Lucia: 但是少一些
Lucia: But fewer of them.
Lucia: 但是ESTJ这个组合好像
Lucia: But it seems like the ESTJ combination...
Alice: 看到就想逃
Alice: Makes me want to run away when I see it.
Lucia: 好像在我的小伙伴里就关系很好
Lucia: Seems to get along well with my buddies.
Lucia: 就是好到大家互相
Lucia: So much so that everyone...
Lucia: 这种MBTA类型的里面好像没有
Lucia: Among these MBTI types, it seems like there aren't any.
Katrina:  但是我闺蜜全是哀人好神奇
Katrina: But all my besties are introverts, how amazing.
Shure:  因为你刚才说你说完这个我感觉
Shure: Because you just said, after you said that, I felt...
Katrina:  我之前一直不明白NAS有啥区别
Katrina: I never understood the difference in NAS before.
Katrina:  我之前一直是ENTJ呃
Katrina: I used to be ENTJ.
Katrina:  分手那会儿变成了ENFJ
Katrina: After breaking up, I became ENFJ.
Katrina:  然后变成感性了
Katrina: Then I became more emotional.
Katrina:  然后后来走出来以后又变成ENTJ
Katrina: After I got over it, I became ENTJ again.
Katrina:  然后现在变成ESTJ
Katrina: And now I’m an ESTJ.
Katrina:  就是现n是长远
Katrina: So, N is for long-term...
Katrina:  s是现务实
Katrina: S is for practical now.
Lucia: 哇好热
Lucia: Wow, it's so hot.
Katrina:  是不是往这走
Katrina: Should we go this way?
Shure:  想和你谈论宇宙和天空
Shure: I want to talk to you about the universe and the sky.
Katrina:  不知道往哪边
Katrina: Don't know which way to go.
Shure: 往哪边走
Katrina:  反正大体方向应该是往这吧
Katrina: Anyway, the general direction should be this way.
Lucia: 我随机选一条路吧哈哈
Lucia: I’ll just randomly pick a path, haha.
Jake: 好好我们听j的
Jake: Okay, okay, let's listen to J.
Shure: 来来石头剪刀布
Shure: Come on, let's play rock-paper-scissors.
Shure: 我赢了就往那边走
Shure: If I win, we go that way.
Lucia: 啊我们要分分组走了吗
Lucia: Ah, are we going to split into groups?
Jake: 没有他们在玄悟
Jake: No, they're just overthinking it.
Jake: 他们做历史的抉择
Jake: They are making a historical choice.
Lucia: 历史的抉择
Lucia: A historical choice.
Alice: 历史的分岔路口
Alice: A historical crossroads.
Jake: 走左还是走右啊
Jake: Left or right?
Lucia: 啊哈你这有别的意思吗
Lucia: Haha, do you mean something else?
Jake: 没有别的意思哈哈哈
Jake: No, nothing else, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈这招是不是要剪掉啊
Lucia: Haha, should we cut this part?
Shure:  你不要瞎
Shure: Don't be silly.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure:  我们这些放到文本里都是没有问题的
Shure: There's no problem putting this in the text.
Lucia: 对对确实确实
Lucia: Yes, yes, absolutely.
Katrina:  然后现在就是
Katrina: And now it's just...
Katrina:  之前就近2年看了一些什么疫情啊
Katrina: Over the past two years, with the pandemic...
Jake: 没有什么意思就是左
Jake: It doesn't mean anything, just left.
Katrina:  合肥水啥的
Katrina: And some issues in Hefei...
Jake: 向左转还是向右转
Jake: Turn left or turn right.
Katrina:  我就觉得过一天是一天吧
Katrina: I just feel like taking it one day at a time.
Katrina:  然后我每天就自己给自己找事
Katrina: And I just find things to do every day.
Tasha: 对我我没有听懂这个梗
Tasha: Yeah, I didn't get that joke.
Lucia: 其实也没事
Lucia: Actually, it's fine.
Lucia: 这是现在的那个啥也很常见的
Lucia: This is quite common nowadays.
Jake: 对对是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes, indeed.
Lucia: 也不一定非得有什么
Lucia: It doesn't necessarily mean anything.
Shure:  在那个时期
Shure: At that time...
Jake: 在那个时期可能就剪刀石头布
Jake: At that time, it might be rock-paper-scissors.
Lucia: 一定要再多加两两多补两刀吗
Lucia: Do we really need to add two more stabs?
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake: 就是就是一分钟之前
Jake: Just a minute ago...
Lucia: 对对对对是这样的
Lucia: Yes, yes, exactly.
Jake: 没有别的意思
Jake: No other meaning.
Jake: 对对因为很难选嘛
Jake: Yes, yes, because it's hard to choose.
Lucia: 因为现在没岔路了
Lucia: Because there are no crossroads now.
Tasha: 好科普一下
Tasha: Okay, let's explain it.
Jake: 你在录吧
Jake: Are you recording?
Jake: 我看看你的灯
Jake: Let me see your light.
Shure: 在录
Shure: Recording.
Jake: 哦确实外面看不太清
Jake: Oh, indeed, it's hard to see from outside.
Jake: 但是得看一看好的
Jake: But we need to check it, okay.
Tasha: 不在录
Tasha: Not recording.
Shure:  我斜斜的往上看一眼就能看到
Shure: I can see it when I look up slightly.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 我这个好像红色的灯
Alice: Mine seems to have a red light.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 哦那你你看一下
Jake: Oh, then take a look.
Jake: 是不是快没电了还是怎么的
Jake: Is it running out of battery or something?
Lucia: 亮好像是还亮着的
Lucia: The light seems to be still on.
Jake: 对红的
Jake: Yeah, it's red.
Jake: 要不就是过热要不就是它过热
Jake: Either it's overheating or it's overheating.
Jake: 它会报警
Jake: It will alarm.
Alice: 这是有点热了 100%的电
Alice: It's a bit hot and the battery is at 100%.
Lucia: 我手机倒是有点过热
Lucia: My phone is a bit overheated.
Lucia: 我手机电池不行了
Lucia: My phone battery is not good.
Lucia: 现在没电
Lucia: It's out of battery now.
Jake: 100%的电你插电呢是吧
Jake: The battery is at 100%, you plugged it in, right?
Alice: yes我一直在充
Alice: Yes, I've been charging it.
Tasha: 我们用了这么久还这么多电
Tasha: We've used it for so long and still so much battery.
Jake: 他插电了
Jake: He plugged it in.
Alice: 因为我在一直充电
Alice: Because I've been charging it.
Jake: 那就合理
Jake: That makes sense.
Jake: 那就是过热
Jake: So it's overheating.
Jake: 应该在阴凉地多走一走
Jake: You should walk around in a shady place to cool it down.
Jake: 降降温
Jake: Cool it down.
Alice: 有点烫烫的嘞
Alice: It's a bit hot.
Jake: 降降温
Jake: Cool it down.
Alice: 小蝴蝶
Alice: Little butterfly.
Alice: 飞远了
Shure:  先在上面滚一圈对
Shure: First, roll around on top.
Shure:  有人要滚一圈吗
Shure: Anyone wants to roll around?
其他人：他要滚下去
Others: He wants to roll down.
Jake: 算了
Jake: Forget it.
Lucia: 为什么要从这诡异起来
Lucia: Why is it weird from here?
其他人：因为草坪可能舒服
Others: Because the lawn might be comfortable.
Katrina:  想滚
Katrina: Want to roll.
Shure:  我说眼镜看好我我给你
Shure: I said, watch my glasses, I'll give them to you.
Lucia: 你把眼镜放到这录着你自己滚下去
Lucia: Put your glasses here and record yourself rolling down.
Shure:  算了别污染数据集
Shure: Forget it, don't pollute the dataset.
Shure:  不然她以为人类的行动方式有一个是滚
Shure: Otherwise, she'll think one of the human actions is rolling.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice: 请你圆润的滚开
Alice: Please roll away smoothly.
Lucia: 这是早早期人类撒欢的珍贵记录
Lucia: This is a precious record of early human frolics.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 就是从此以后就是
Jake: So from now on, it's like
Jake: 呃如果一个人想到那边
Jake: Uh, if someone wants to go there
Jake: 然后就会Rick man的一个滚下去的做法
Jake: Then they'll do a Rickman roll down the hill
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈真的
Lucia: Hahaha, really
Jake: 哈哈哈哈这样效
Jake: Hahaha, it's effective this way
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed
Lucia: 这样效率更高
Lucia: It's more efficient this way
Alice: 探戈就是
Alice: Tango is just
Lucia: 这是人工智障吧这是
Lucia: This is artificial stupidity, right?
Alice: 探呀探着走
Shure:  因为你看咱们刚才走了一个陡坡
Shure: Because we just walked down a steep slope
Shure:  然后咱们走的时间可能就是很慢
Shure: And it probably took us a long time
Shure:  这条路呢
Shure: This path
Shure:  我从这到那个下坡滚这时间更快了
Shure: Rolling down the slope would be much faster
Lucia: 啊所以
Lucia: Ah, so
Lucia: 当给出的指令是计算最快路线的时候
Lucia: When instructed to calculate the fastest route
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 就会滚
Lucia: It'll roll
Shure:  对对
Shure: Yes, yes
Shure:  一直以为
Shure: Always thought
Tasha: 啊就会走这里
Tasha: Ah, it'll walk here
Tasha: 走超进道了
Tasha: Taking a shortcut
Jake: 哎抄近道然后走的话晚上他就给我
Jake: Yeah, taking a shortcut, then at night, it would
Alice: 高德地图不管我能不能过去
Alice: Gaode map doesn't care if I can pass
Alice: 反正他就给我一个穿墙的选项
Alice: Anyway, it gives me an option to go through walls
Alice: 是不是也是这样的
Alice: Is it like that?
Shure:  有可能
Shure: Could be
Jake: 穿墙 这不行
Jake: Going through walls, that's impossible
Lucia: 那个应该是他数据没及时更新
Lucia: Maybe its data isn't updated timely
Lucia: 就是他不知道那分上
Lucia: It doesn't know that part
Jake: 对这是不够智能
Jake: Yeah, it's not intelligent enough
Jake: 就是滚下去是可以实现的
Jake: Rolling down is achievable
Jake: 穿墙是不可实现的
Jake: Going through walls is not
Lucia: 你怎么知道
Lucia: How do you know?
Lucia: 他不是想让你把墙砸掉啊
Lucia: Maybe it wants you to break the wall
Jake: 哈哈哦哈哈哈
Jake: Haha oh hahaha
Alice: 管我的死活是吧哈哈哈
Alice: It doesn't care about my life or death, right? Hahaha
Alice: 哎在这浇花很方便
Alice: Ah, watering the plants here is convenient
Alice: 直接往这一冲
Alice: Just pour it right here.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 水顺着就流下去了
Alice: The water will just flow down.
Jake: 是的
Jake: Exactly.
Shure:  这就梯田是吗
Shure: Is this a terrace?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 水好亮
Alice: The water is so shiny.
Tasha: 波光粼粼
Tasha: It's sparkling.
Tasha:粼粼
Tasha: Sparkling.
Lucia: 我们现在是要玩飞花令了吗哈哈
Lucia: Are we going to play "Feihualing" now? Haha.
Jake: 来看你们表演
Jake: Let's watch you guys perform.
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 就是你们刚才那个波光粼粼
Lucia: It's just that you said sparkling.
Lucia: 我突然想起来昨
Lucia: Suddenly reminded me of...
Lucia: 天的成语接龙
Lucia: Yesterday's idiom game.
Lucia: 然后就想起来废话令那个提案
Lucia: And then I remembered the proposal for "Feihualing".
Alice: 我先来
Alice: I'll go first.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure: 这是球队的帽子
Shure: This is the team's hat.
Lucia: 对对巴萨了
Lucia: Yeah, it's for Barca.
Jake: 这什么球队
Jake: Which team is it?
Jake: 看一下哦
Jake: Let me see.
Jake: 阿塞尔的
Jake: It's Arsenal.
Lucia: 真的在真的在
Lucia: It's really there.
Lucia: 那个诺坎普买的哈哈
Lucia: I bought it at Camp Nou. Haha.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Alice: 成语接龙
Alice: Idiom game.
Lucia: 我现在不是不是巴萨的球迷了
Lucia: I'm not a Barca fan anymore.
Lucia: 也不是不是
Lucia: Not really.
Lucia: 就是还没有到路转不是
Lucia: I haven't completely turned away.
Lucia: 也没有到粉转黑的程度
Lucia: And I haven't completely turned against them.
Alice: 第一个为所欲为
Alice: The first one, "do as you please".
Lucia: 就粉转路吧
Lucia: Just turned into a casual fan.
Alice: 下一个哈哈哈哈
Alice: Next one. Hahaha.
Lucia: 因为这两年管理太混乱了
Lucia: Because the management has been so chaotic these past two years.
Alice: 成语接龙
Alice: Idiom game.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Alice: 为所欲为
Alice: "Do as you please".
Lucia: 我正在试图找一个新球队
Lucia: I'm trying to find a new team.
Shure:  维他命C
Shure: Vitamin C.
Lucia: 现在目前的备选是阿森纳
Lucia: The current alternative is Arsenal.
Jake: 阿森纳大炮
Jake: Arsenal's cannon.
Alice: 维他命c也能是成语吗
Alice: Can vitamin C be an idiom too?
Shure:  让他们去打猎吧
Shure: Let them go hunting.
Shure:  给大家看看人类早期打猎
Shure: Show everyone early human hunting.
Shure:  珍贵影像
Shure: Precious footage.
Tasha: 随便买的
Tasha: Just bought it randomly.
Jake: 但前面是有卖东西的地方吗
Jake: But was there a place to buy things before?
Tasha: 社区便利店
Tasha: Community convenience store.
Jake: 像吗这个像吗
Jake: Does it look like this?
Jake: 社区便利店确实是
Jake: Community convenience store, indeed.
Tasha: 便民
Tasha: Convenient.
Shure:  但是他有没有可能在墙那里面呢
Shure: But could it be inside the wall?
Tasha: 让他伸出来
Tasha: Let it stick out.
Tasha: 爷爷给我一瓶水
Tasha: Grandpa, give me a bottle of water.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 手机连成一串
Jake: Connect the phones in a row.
Jake: 谢谢您哎呀
Jake: Thank you, oh man.
Jake: 对这个
Jake: Yes, this one.
Shure:  这
Shure: This.
Jake: 对啊得有一个包嘛
Jake: Yeah, there needs to be a bag.
Katrina:  这是什么花
Katrina: What kind of flower is this?
Shure:  包好沉啊
Shure: The bag is so heavy.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我不会说出去的
Lucia: Haha, I won't tell anyone.
Katrina:  我感觉北方跟南方的见植物
Katrina: I feel the plants in the north and south...
Lucia: 快乐吃瓜哈哈
Lucia: Happy melon eating, haha.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  长见识了
Katrina: I learned something new.
Alice: 什么鬼
Alice: What the heck?
Alice: 魔鬼我错过了什么
Alice: Devil, what did I miss?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 没错过是吧
Lucia: Didn't miss, right?
Lucia: 你问微微哈哈
Lucia: Ask Tasha, haha.
Tasha: 什么都没有
Tasha: Nothing at all.
Tasha: 啦啦啦
Tasha: La la la.
Katrina:  我还带了加绒卫衣呢
Katrina: I even brought a fleece hoodie.
Jake: 这确实出不去对吧
Jake: This really can't get out, right?
Tasha: 便民空间
Tasha: Convenient space.
Tasha: 里面没有便民超市
Tasha: There isn't a convenience store inside.
Jake: 那这个空间是干嘛的呢
Jake: So what's this space for?
Katrina:  这没有口
Katrina: There's no entrance.
Katrina:  那前面是不是口啊
Katrina: Is the entrance up ahead?
Tasha: 类似于那种社区空间
Tasha: It's kind of like a community space.
Katrina:  前面是不是就是门出去
Katrina: Is that the door to go out?
Jake: 打麻将用的
Jake: For playing mahjong.
Tasha: 呃也许吧
Tasha: Uh, maybe.
Shure:  应该是
Shure: Probably.
Lucia: 还有乒乓球估计
Lucia: And for ping pong, I guess.
Tasha: 读书
Tasha: Reading.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 乒乓球
Tasha: Ping pong.
Jake: 那这也
Jake: Then this also...
Katrina:  耳朵
Katrina: Ears.
Tasha: 哎但这有卖水的门口
Tasha: Oh, but there's a water vending machine at the entrance.
Katrina:  那好像能出去
Katrina: Looks like you can go out.
Katrina:  出去就过来
Katrina: Go out and come back.
Katrina:  应该这种修的这种道都会用
Katrina: They'd probably use this path too.
Lucia: 有被晒到
Lucia: Getting some sun.
Katrina:  算吧
Katrina: Sort of.
Shure:  我们的野餐
Shure: Our picnic.
Katrina:  我只是只会做大概的计划
Katrina: I can only do rough planning.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Shure:  我们的野餐就是刚刚在在那个栏杆上
Shure: Our picnic was just on that railing over there.
Shure:  然后吃狮子
Shure: And eating lions.
Jake: 跟鱼一起吃披萨对
Jake: Eating pizza with the fish, right?
Shure:  对好爆掉一个手串
Shure: Yeah, and a bracelet exploded.
Tasha: 什么生态共享
Tasha: What's eco-sharing?
Shure:  献祭他
Shure: Sacrifice it.
Lucia: 啊他说他在说我们的野餐计划
Lucia: Ah, he’s talking about our picnic plan.
Lucia: 就是刚才和淤挤
Lucia: Just now, and squeezing in.
Tasha: 生态共享
Tasha: Eco-sharing.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 你看
Lucia: Look.
Jake: 还有第二餐
Jake: And a second meal.
Jake: 其实我们还有几个披萨
Jake: Actually, we still have a few more pizzas.
Lucia: 这次喂谁呢哈哈哈
Lucia: Who are we feeding this time, hahaha.
Tasha: 还有一盒
Tasha: There's one more box.
Jake: 哈哈哈我们还有一盒披萨
Jake: Hahaha, we still have a box of pizza.
Katrina:  被留当晚饭了
Katrina: Kept for dinner.
Lucia: 可是这里没有那个
Lucia: But there's no such thing here.
Tasha: 好像是羊肉披萨
Tasha: Seems like it's lamb pizza.
Katrina:  现在小龙虾还挺好吃
Katrina: Crawfish is pretty tasty now.
Lucia: 没有那个海鸥耶
Lucia: There are no seagulls here.
Jake: 北京竟然没有海鸥
Jake: Beijing doesn't have seagulls.
Tasha: 北京为什么会有海鸥
Tasha: Why would Beijing have seagulls?
Lucia: 北京也不靠海吧好像
Lucia: Beijing isn't by the sea, I think.
Katrina:  我身上穿的就是海鸥
Katrina: What I'm wearing is a seagull.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun.
Tasha: 不行了
Tasha: I can't do it anymore.
Tasha: 又晒又热
Tasha: It's both sunny and hot.
Lucia: 行我要两个都摘掉我就给他拿下来
Lucia: Okay, I'll take both off and give them to him.
Lucia: 别掉了
Lucia: Don't drop them.
Katrina:  我灯还亮吗
Katrina: Are my lights still on?
Katrina:  我是不是该充电了
Katrina: Should I charge it now?
Lucia: 对我带了个耳机
Lucia: Yeah, I brought an earphone.
Jake: 对很赛博
Jake: Yeah, very cyber.
Lucia: 我已经为了照顾这个眼镜没有戴大
Lucia: I didn't wear the big ones to take care of these glasses.
Tasha: 这是要出去了吗
Tasha: Are we heading out?
Lucia: 戴了头戴耳机了哈哈
Lucia: I wore the headsets, haha.
Alice: 啊可以出去
Alice: Ah, we can go out.
Tasha: 已经出去了
Tasha: Already out.
Tasha: 都没有遇到水
Tasha: Didn't even meet any water.
Jake: 没有水
Jake: No water.
Tasha: 走错路哭了
Tasha: Took the wrong way and cried.
Lucia: 保利发展控股竟然在这里
Lucia: Poly Developments Holdings is actually here.
Alice: 蜻蜓跌水
Alice: Dragonfly dipped in water.
Alice: 真的吗
Alice: Really?
Lucia: 这PRD不会都是保利的吧
Lucia: Isn't this PRD all Poly's?
Lucia: 这个是符合符合计划的吗嗯
Lucia: Is this according to the plan?
Jake: 可能没有特别符合
Jake: Maybe not exactly.
Lucia: 那我们怎么办
Lucia: Then what do we do?
Jake: 那我们在可能绕回去吧
Jake: Then maybe we should loop back.
Lucia: 要绕回去呢
Lucia: We need to loop back?
Lucia: 我们修正一下路线
Lucia: Let's adjust the route.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 可误路线选错了
Tasha: Wrong route, what a mistake.
Shure:  不行我们去超市的时候再买水
Shure: It's okay, we'll buy water when we go to the supermarket.
Jake: 那可能有点这边真的没有水哈
Jake: That might be a bit... there's really no water here.
Jake: 这可是居民区的呀
Jake: This is a residential area.
Jake: 我们已经
Jake: We've already
Shure:  要走到小区里
Shure: Gotta walk into the community.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Katrina:  刚那便利店
Katrina: That convenience store just now
Katrina:  只能从这出去再绕回去
Katrina: We can only get out from here and circle back.
Jake: 对我们偏离路线偏离了一公里
Jake: Yeah, we deviated from the route by one kilometer.
Jake: 哈哈哈没有关系没有关系
Jake: Hahaha, it's okay, it's okay.
Katrina:  yeah
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure:  一定是在j人的计划中吧
Shure: It's definitely part of j's plan, right?
Katrina:  yeah
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 一定有他的道理
Lucia: He must have his reasons.
Alice: 那我们走水路吧
Alice: Then let's go by water.
Alice: 感觉那里面凉快
Alice: It feels cooler over there.
Lucia: 我们可以沿着它走
Lucia: We can walk along it.
Jake: 我们可以过个马路得了来都来了
Jake: We can cross the road since we're already here.
Alice: 来都来了
Alice: Since we're already here.
Lucia: 那就我走到保利的那块地坪上去
Lucia: Then I'll walk to the Poly area over there.
Jake: 对面是不是也没有什么
Jake: Is there anything on the other side?
Jake: 还是那就走水路会
Jake: Or should we just go by water?
Jake: 还是这边阴凉一点
Jake: It's a bit cooler over here.
Lucia: 上说太阳现在是这个方向
Lucia: According to the sun, it's in this direction now.
Lucia: 所以可能都不是很阴凉
Lucia: So it might not be very shady.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 我们不能游过去吗
Alice: Can't we just swim across?
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Alice: 可以
Lucia: yes you can我帮你保管眼睛
Lucia: Yes you can, I'll keep an eye on your glasses.
Shure:  但眼镜不防水
Shure: But the glasses aren't waterproof.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We
Alice: 谁会游泳呢
Alice: Who can swim?
Shure:  我我小时候在这野湖里游过
Shure: I used to swim in this wild lake when I was a kid.
Lucia: 其实我会哈哈
Lucia: Actually, I can swim, haha.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 回头
Jake: Turn back.
Jake: 回到起点
Jake: Back to the starting point.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Katrina:  回到起点远吗
Katrina:  要不要先买水再回到起点
Katrina: Should we buy water first and then go back to the starting point?
Jake: 也可以水在这附近还是
Jake: Sure, is there water nearby or...
Katrina:  水就刚刚那个便利店
Katrina: The water is at that convenience store we just passed.
Katrina:  只是从这绕绕出去一下
Katrina: We just need to go around from here.
Jake: 好那绕一圈
Jake: Okay, let's go around.
Jake: 再绕一圈
Jake: One more round.
Jake: 把小区给建了
Jake: We'll build a community while we're at it.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 但是小区没有那什么我们能进吗
Shure: But the community doesn't have that, can we get in?
Lucia: 刷脸不可以吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Can't we just use face recognition? Hahaha.
Jake: 咱就说要买水
Jake: We'll just say we're here to buy water.
Jake: 光天化日之下我们能干什么
Jake: What can we do in broad daylight?
Katrina:  应该能进去吧这边
Katrina: We should be able to get in, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 拍VLOG吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Maybe shoot a vlog or something. Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哎呀
Lucia: Oh no!
Alice:哎妈 吓死我了
Alice: That scared me.
Alice: 啊对不起哦
Alice: Oh, sorry.
Alice: 没有没有没有
Alice: No, no, no.
Alice: 我在想事情
Alice: I was just thinking about something.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 在想什么呀
Lucia: What were you thinking about?
Alice: 我在想我五一怎么回家
Alice: I was thinking about how to get home for May Day.
Alice: 要不要回家
Alice: Whether I should go home or not.
Alice: 你呢
Alice: What about you?
Alice: 你的五一安排是什么
Alice: What are your plans for May Day?
Lucia: 我五一安排在家躺着
Lucia: I'm planning to just stay home.
Lucia: 因为五一放假出去玩的人太多了
Lucia: Because there are too many people traveling during May Day.
Alice: 对我也是
Alice: Yeah, same here.
Alice: 我就在想
Alice: I was just thinking.
Alice: 回家躺跟在寝室躺
Alice: Is there any big difference between lying at home and lying in the dorm?
Alice: 有什么本质上特别的区别吗
Alice: Is there any essential difference?
Lucia: 回家躺可以躺的
Lucia: Lying at home, you get to lie on your own bed.
Lucia: 你的床更大确实
Lucia: Your bed is bigger, that's for sure.
Alice: 确实
Alice: True.
Jake: 我看到了两个字
Jake: I saw two words.
Lucia: 哒哒哒哒
Lucia: Ta-da, ta-da.
Jake: 超市对
Jake: Supermarket, right.
Lucia: 这进不去耶
Lucia: We can't get in here.
Katrina:  这进不去
Katrina: I can't get in.
Katrina:  只能在这看有没有买水的
Katrina: We can only check if anyone is selling water here.
Jake: 有超市好强啊
Jake: There's a supermarket, that's awesome.
Lucia: 我每次放假的时候都更喜欢哈哈
Lucia: Every time I have a holiday, I enjoy it more and more, haha.
Lucia: 家里蹲
Lucia: Staying at home.
Lucia: 因为外面人太多了除非迫不得已
Lucia: Because there are too many people outside unless I have no choice.
Alice: 我给你看
Alice: Let me show you.
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Jake: 羽毛球
Jake: Badminton.
Alice: 给你看床上
Alice: Let me show you on the bed.
Alice: 过完那天野营的四月啊
Alice: After that day of camping in April...
Lucia: 这是哪天啊
Lucia: Which day was that?
Lucia: 清明节吗
Lucia: Qingming Festival?
Alice: 对
Alice: Yes.
Lucia: 对妈耶
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Alice: 野营的人比树还多
Alice: There were more campers than trees.
Alice: 我那天快被吓死了
Alice: I was almost scared to death that day.
Alice: 但那天天还蛮好的
Alice: But the weather was pretty good that day.
Alice: 我们去逛了
Alice: We went for a walk.
Alice: 不对我们去放风筝了
Alice: No, we went to fly kites.
Lucia: 妈耶
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Alice: 你最近会在北京待吗
Alice: Are you staying in Beijing recently?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 我要是在北京待我还得专门租个房子
Lucia: If I stay in Beijing, I'll have to rent a place.
Alice: 那你是这个结束之后先回家还是
Alice: So, after this ends, are you going home first or...
Lucia: 我现在是这样想的
Lucia: That's what I'm thinking right now.
Lucia: 不过我也有可能需要在北京办点事情
Lucia: But I might need to handle some things in Beijing too.
Lucia: 所以不是很确定
Lucia: So, I'm not very sure.
Alice: 有无怡宝有看到了
Alice: Any Yibao? Did you see it?
Jake: 呃可以报吧
Jake: Uh, can we report it?
Jake: 你们扫吧
Jake: You guys scan it.
Alice: 有人喝矿泉水吗
Alice: Does anyone want mineral water?
Jake: 嗯不喝
Jake: Hmm, no thanks.
Lucia: 好多种类
Lucia: So many choices.
Lucia: 我选择恐惧症犯了
Lucia: I have choice anxiety.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 一起付
Jake: Let's pay together.
Lucia: 我要这个
Lucia: I want this one.
Alice: 好你要哪个
Alice: Okay, which one do you want?
Jake: 我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 帮我选一个吧
Jake: Help me choose one.
Lucia: 你有选择恐惧症吗
Lucia: Do you have decision anxiety?
Jake: 谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 这个就算了
Jake: Never mind this one.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 我知道我可以say no
Jake: I know I can say no.
Jake: 我不能我不知道这个吧
Jake: I can't, I don't know about this one.
Alice: 这个吧
Alice: How about this one?
Jake: 这个也可以
Jake: This one works too.
Jake: 这个可以谢谢您
Jake: This one is fine, thank you.
Lucia: 我觉得值得试试东鹏特饮
Lucia: I think it's worth trying Dongpeng Special Drink.
Lucia: 困了累了喝东鹏特饮
Lucia: If you're tired or sleepy, drink Dongpeng Special Drink.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 啊哎
Lucia: Ah, hey.
Lucia: 怎么能一样啊
Lucia: How can it be the same?
Lucia: 你知道薇薇选的是什么
Lucia: Do you know what Tasha chose?
Lucia: 说不定我们三个都一样
Lucia: Maybe all three of us chose the same thing.
Lucia: 哎对
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Jake: 薇薇还没选
Jake: Tasha hasn't chosen yet.
Lucia: 他拿来尖叫
Lucia: He brought a scream.
其他人：123456
Others: 123456.
其他人：32一共
Others: 32 in total.
Jake: 啊扫的这么快
Jake: Wow, scanned so fast.
其他人：32 35
Others: 32, 35.
Jake:  OK行
Jake: OK, got it.
Jake: 我怎么付你
Jake: How do I pay you?
Jake: 我扫这个行
Jake: Can I scan this?
其他人：行
Others: Sure.
Lucia: 微信收款
Lucia: WeChat payment.
Jake: 35
Jake: 35.
其他人：嗯
Others: Hmm.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 呃走
Jake: Uh, let's go.
其他人：微信收款35元
Others: WeChat payment of 35 yuan.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Shure:  而且我还没没什么反应
Shure: And I haven't had any reaction yet.
Jake: 一个7新币的水
Jake: A $7 water.
Jake: 哈哈哈也可以
Jake: Hahaha, it works too.
Lucia: 这个7 新币吗
Lucia: Is this 7 SGD?
Jake: 没有就是花了35嘛
Jake: No, it cost 35.
Jake: 相当于我买了一个七新币的水
Jake: It's like I bought a 7 SGD water.
Jake: 也不是不不常见
Jake: It's not that uncommon.
Jake: 哈哈哈就是
Jake: Hahaha, yeah.
Katrina:  慢点慢点慢点
Katrina: Slow down, slow down.
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's okay.
Tasha: 嗯哈哈哈
Tasha: Hmm, hahaha.
Shure:  怎么说下一站吗
Shure: What's the next stop?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  下一站去哪
Katrina: Where's the next stop?
Katrina:  要不直接在这打车也行
Katrina: Or we can just take a cab here.
Jake: 也行啊下一站去哪啊
Jake: That works too, where to next?
Shure:  我们找找个好打车的地
Shure: Let's find a good spot to catch a cab.
Alice: 买什么调料跟什么肉啥来着
Alice: What seasoning and meat do we need to buy again?
Jake: 呃不好意思
Jake: Uh, sorry.
Jake: 去哪买啊
Jake: Where to buy?
Shure:  找一个大一点的
Shure: Let's find a bigger one.
Shure:  商超吧还是
Shure: Like a big supermarket.
Alice: 有没有那种什么食材
Alice: Is there a wholesale market?
Alice: 批发
Alice: Market?
Alice: 市场那种直接带串好签的不也行吗
Alice: Where they have pre-skewered meat, wouldn't that work?
Tasha: 一旦我发起这个话题你就会很认同
Tasha: Once I bring up this topic, you'll totally agree.
Alice: 碳油刷子
Alice: Charcoal, oil, and brushes.
Katrina:  大超市
Katrina: Big supermarket.
Tasha: 超市里走
Tasha: Let's go to the supermarket.
Tasha: 嗯很凉快
Tasha: Hmm, it's nice and cool.
Katrina:  这200米居然有个盒马鲜生
Katrina: There's a Hema Fresh 200 meters away.
Katrina:  200米居然只有
Katrina: Only 200 meters.
Jake: 一定有点
Jake: There's definitely...
Shure:  四四四百米
Shure: 400 meters.
Katrina:  400米有个河马先生
Katrina: 400 meters to Hema Fresh.
Jake: 走吧走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina:  是河马是吗
Katrina: It's Hema, right?
其他人：去盒马可以把晚饭解决了
Others: We can settle dinner at Hema.
Shure:  走带路
Shure: Lead the way.
Katrina:  那就盒马
Katrina: Let's go to Hema.
Katrina:  直接买那个肉
Katrina: Just buy the meat.
Katrina:  然后烤肉
Katrina: And then grill it.
Jake: 还有对
Jake: Also, right.
Tasha: 那还回公园吗
Tasha: So, are we going back to the park?
Jake: 不回了不回了吧
Jake: Nah, we're not going back.
Lucia: 会不会有点晒啊
Lucia: Isn't it a bit sunny?
Lucia: 前两天都没有这种烈日下徒步的环节
Lucia: We didn't have this kind of hike under the scorching sun the past few days.
Lucia: 今天我一来这种
Lucia: And today, as soon as I come...
Lucia: 我应该打打个伞
Lucia: I should've brought an umbrella.
Lucia: 我其实带了一把伞在箱子里
Lucia: Actually, I did bring one, it's in my suitcase.
Lucia: 我们是今天晚上烤吗
Lucia: Are we grilling tonight?
Jake: 哦哦哦那你不喝
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, you're not drinking?
Jake: 你不喝了是吧
Jake: You're done drinking, right?
Jake: 哎呀通州公安局
Jake: Oh no, Tongzhou Police Station.
Jake: 大家想想大家想想有没有要要报案的
Jake: Everyone think, is there anyone who needs to report a case?
Jake: 顺便就哈哈哈哈
Jake: While we're at it, hahaha.
Tasha: 我迟到了
Tasha: I'm late.
Tasha: i'm late
Jake: late what
Jake: Late for what?
Jake: 哇好快好牛啊
Jake: Wow, that was fast and awesome.
Jake: 一切都在掌握之中
Jake: Everything is under control.
其他人：你来拿吧我不想拿了
Others: You take it, I don't want to.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake: 逛逛商场
Jake: Let's go to the mall.
Alice: 风云再起
Alice: The adventure continues.
Jake: 这个商场档次如何
Jake: How's the quality of this mall?
Alice: 你要抓娃娃
Alice: Do you want to play the claw machine?
Jake: 风云再起是什么
Jake: What's "The adventure continues"?
Lucia: 呃呃看起来像健身俱乐部
Lucia: Uh, it looks like a gym.
Alice: 呃电
Alice: Uh, no.
Alice: 不是是那种打电动的
Alice: It's actually an arcade.
Jake: 抓走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha: 走
Tasha: Let's go.
Shure:  哈哈哈不行
Shure: Hahaha, no way.
Jake: 什么不行
Jake: What do you mean, no way?
Lucia: 哈什么不行
Lucia: Haha, what do you mean, no way?
Jake: 都行都行
Jake: Everything's fine.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Alice: 他们在另一个话题
Alice: They're on another topic.
Jake: 哦什么不行啊
Jake: Oh, what's not okay?
Tasha: 哦哈
Tasha: Oh, haha.
Jake: 什么不行
Jake: What do you mean it won't work?
Tasha: 不知道我以为风云再起不行
Tasha: I thought it wouldn't work again.
Jake: 风云再起为啥不行
Jake: Why wouldn't it work again?
Lucia: 我觉得看起来像啊
Lucia: I think it looks like it.
Lucia: 那有可能是游戏厅旁边写了一个游戏
Lucia: Maybe there's a game written next to the arcade.
Alice: 对是的啊
Alice: Yes, that's right.
Alice: 我的儿子怎么在这
Alice: Why is my son here?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake: 哦你的儿子哦
Jake: Oh, your son, huh?
Alice: 旅行青蛙
Alice: Traveling Frog.
Alice: 我的儿子怎么在这
Alice: Why is my son here?
Lucia: 他旅行到这里了
Lucia: He traveled here.
Jake: 哎我们先
Jake: Hey, let's first...
Jake: 我我们我们先在商场里边整点活吧
Jake: Let's first do some stuff inside the mall.
Jake: 先晃悠晃悠
Jake: Wander around a bit.
Jake: 然后再买东西再提走对
Jake: Then we'll buy things and take them away, right?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Sure.
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Sure, sure.
Shure:  我们去小米买点电电池哈哈哈
Shure: Let's go to Xiaomi to buy some batteries, haha.
Katrina:  还有好特卖呢
Katrina: There's also a good sale.
Lucia: 好特卖哦
Lucia: A good sale, huh?
Katrina:  对啊好特卖
Katrina: Yeah, a good sale.
Lucia: 好特卖
Lucia: Good sale.
Katrina:  我最喜欢买
Katrina: I love sales.
Katrina:  好特卖好特卖好特卖好特卖
Katrina: Good sale, good sale, good sale, good sale.
Lucia: 对对对因为比较便宜
Lucia: Yes, yes, because it's cheaper.
Jake: 好好特卖是什么
Jake: What's a good sale?
Lucia: 那个特价店对对对
Lucia: That discount store, right, right.
Jake: 等等会等会
Jake: Wait a minute.
Jake: 我我们好像还没对齐
Jake: I think we aren't aligned yet.
Jake: 现在甚至现在
Jake: Even now, even now.
Jake: 对一下把把把他叫过来来来来
Jake: Align it, call him over, come on, come on.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
Shure:  哦我们出发的时候忘看这个
Shure: Oh, we forgot to check this when we set off.
Jake: 对没看这个东西对好
Jake: Right, didn't check this thing, right, okay.
Jake: 3:47 行
Jake: 3:47, alright.
Alice: 你抓娃娃厉害吗
Alice: Are you good at claw machines?
Tasha: 呃没关系
Tasha: Uh, doesn't matter.
Tasha: 杨老板付钱
Tasha: Jake will pay.
Lucia: 3块钱 3都3块钱了
Lucia: It's 3 yuan, 3 yuan already.
Lucia: 北京已经这个行情了吗
Lucia: Is this the market rate in Beijing now?
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Tasha: 觉得在团购上买会不会便宜
Tasha: Do you think it would be cheaper to buy on a group-buying platform?
Jake: 100个币是什么意思
Jake: What does 100 coins mean?
Jake: 100个币抓几次
Jake: How many tries for 100 coins?
Alice: 他们有的是3个币
Alice: Some are 3 coins.
Alice: 有的5个币
Alice: Some are 5 coins.
Alice: 这种抓一次
Alice: That's for one try.
Tasha: 30次吧
Tasha: About 30 tries.
Shure:  3个币左右
Shure: Around 3 coins.
Jake: 那我100个币你们你们自由分配
Jake: Then I have 100 coins for you all to distribute freely.
Shure:  就位好
Shure: Ready, set.
Katrina:  好吧那就微信购
Katrina: Alright, then we buy on WeChat.
Jake: 好吧好行
Jake: Alright, fine.
Katrina:  是不是便宜点
Katrina: Isn't it cheaper?
Shure:  呼呼
Shure: Haha.
Katrina:  就扫这个嘛那89
Katrina: Just scan this, right? Then 89.
Lucia: 那个微信购币好像89100币
Lucia: That WeChat coin purchase is like 89 for 100 coins.
Katrina:  耶
Katrina: Yay.
Shure:  若每人夸一句杨哥好帅
Shure: If everyone compliments Jake, saying he's handsome.
Alice: 有那个大众点评哎
Alice: There's that Dianping app.
Alice: 不对那叫啥来着团购
Alice: No, wait, what's it called? Group-buying.
Jake: 100个币89是吧
Jake: 100 coins for 89, right?
Tasha: 这个会不会便宜一些
Tasha: Would this be cheaper?
Shure:  应该差不多耶
Shure: Should be about the same.
Tasha: 就这样好go
Tasha: Alright, let's go.
Katrina:  这应该是什么
Katrina: What should this be?
Katrina:  抖音套餐
Katrina: A TikTok package.
Katrina:  嗯然后再哇
Katrina: Hmm, then wow.
Jake: 哦不然还得剪是吧
Jake: Oh, otherwise we have to edit, right?
Jake: 又是一个离谱的数据
Jake: Another ridiculous number.
Katrina:  这多少
Katrina: How much is this?
Jake: 对吧
Jake: Right?
Katrina:  84 他这89
Katrina: 84, this one's 89.
Katrina:  应该差不多吧
Katrina: Should be about the same.
Katrina:  老板觉得5块钱不是钱
Katrina: The boss thinks 5 yuan is nothing.
Jake: 他动了
Jake: It's moving.
Shure:  啊你需要点一下对哦对
Shure: Ah, you need to click, right, oh right.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Katrina:  哇
Lucia: 好神奇
Katrina:  来吧
Shure:  来吧
Tasha: 来吧
Jake: 来吧
Lucia: 来吧
Tasha: 我们分一下
Alice: 一人抓两把得了
Katrina:  抓娃娃去
Lucia: 来吧
Lucia: 是多少个啊
Katrina:  你会抓娃娃吗
Shure:  开玩笑高玩好吗
Katrina:  我没抓到过
Alice: 来两个吧
Jake: 哈哈哈我们也抓吧
Jake: 你你我看你我我拿拿俩吧
Alice: 我们一起抓吧
Alice: 啊我不怎么玩
Jake: 哎对可以啊可以啊你可以
Jake: Yeah, that's fine, you can do it.
Jake: 没事没事没事没事找我领就好
Jake: No worries, no worries, just come to me to get it.
Alice: 你想抓什么
Alice: What do you want to grab?
其他人：我都可以
Others: I'm fine with anything.
其他人： 找一个最可爱的
Others: Pick the cutest one.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
其他人：就是好像不能分在这抓
Others: It seems like you can't divide and grab here.
其他人：你就得全部到一个机子上他才有概率
Others: You need to gather all on one machine to have a chance.
Jake: 是不是不只抓娃娃呀
Jake: Aren't we grabbing more than just dolls?
Alice: 别的都可以
Alice: Everything else is fine too.
Alice: 这种项目都可以
Alice: These kinds of games are all good.
Jake: OK OK多久没回猫了
Jake: OK OK, how long has it been since you last visited a cat?
Lucia: 您是多久没回国了
Lucia: How long has it been since you returned to the country?
Jake: 哈哈哈真真没来过这些地方
Jake: Haha, I really haven't been to these places before.
Alice: 或者你去玩跳舞机什么也可以
Alice: Or you could play the dance machine or something.
Alice: 来上去吧
Alice: Come on, go up.
Alice: 乾坤未定
Alice: The future is uncertain.
Shure:  你我皆是牛马
Shure: We are all just working hard.
Alice: 牛马
Alice: Working hard.
Jake: 这是浪费了我一个币子是吧
Jake: Did I just waste one token?
Jake: 哈哈哈那那边有那个架子鼓
Jake: Hahaha, there's a drum set over there.
Alice: 三个吧
Alice: Three, I guess.
Shure:  啊有吗
Shure: Oh, is there?
Lucia: 那边有架子鼓
Lucia: There's a drum set over there.
Jake: 那边架子鼓
Jake: Yeah, a drum set over there.
Lucia: 你要不要玩一下
Lucia: Do you want to play it?
Jake: 围观你打一圈呗
Jake: Let's all watch you play a bit.
Lucia: 让我观摩一下贪玩
Lucia: Let me see you having fun.
Alice: 好臭啊
Alice: It smells so bad.
Jake: 这行吗这设备够灵玩吗
Jake: Is this good? Is the equipment sensitive enough?
Shure:  够了够了
Shure: It's good, it's good.
Jake: 可以是吧
Jake: It's okay, right?
Jake: 等会我把大家都叫过来
Jake: Wait, I'll call everyone over.
Jake: 你先等会
Jake: Just wait a moment.
Shure:  再来再来一个
Shure: Do it again, do it again.
Shure:  币老板哎好
Shure: Boss Bi, okay.
Alice: 给你拍个背面照可以吗
Alice: Can I take a picture of your back?
Alice: 现在开始吗就
Alice: Should we start now?
Shure:  反正他有好几次机会应该
Shure: Anyway, he has several chances.
Alice: 好那我录着你哈哈
Jake: 这多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Shure:  4个币子
Shure: 4 coins.
Jake: 4个币的
Jake: 4 coins, huh?
Shure:  好像能打3首吧应该
Shure: Yeah, you can probably play 3 songs with it.
Shure:  这个很赚的
Shure: It's a pretty good deal.
Jake: 四四个壁子
Jake: Four coins...
Jake: 你要水平高是不是可以连打
Jake: If you're good, can you keep playing?
Shure:  好像是吧
Shure: I think so.
Jake: 不知道啊来
Jake: Not sure, let's try.
Jake: 啊给投过了啊行
Jake: Ah, we've already put the coins in, okay.
Alice: 投过了投过了
Alice: Coins are in, coins are in.
Shure:  啊太丢人了
Shure: Ah, this is so embarrassing.
Shure:  game over了
Shure: Game over.
Alice: 我操哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Damn, hahahaha.
Shure:  我靠哈哈哈
Shure: Gosh, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈记录在案
Jake: Hahahahaha, it's on record.
Alice: 哈
Alice: Ha.
Jake: 首席首席鼓
Jake: Chief, chief drummer.
Shure:  不行不行哈哈哈
Shure: No way, no way, hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Katrina:  啊哎
Katrina: Ah, hey.
Katrina:  但是他一直在边上你知道吗
Katrina: But he was always there, you know?
Katrina:  就搞得很心动
Katrina: It made me really excited.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 啊这么厉害
Jake: Wow, that's impressive.
Katrina:  哈哈装饰屋子有了
Katrina: Haha, now we can decorate the house.
Jake: 挺好挺好挺好
Jake: That's great, that's great.
Jake: 啊在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Alice: 坠了一下
Alice: Got a bit drunk.
Alice: 再来一次吧
Alice: Let's go again.
Katrina:  士气大增
Katrina: Morale boosted.
Katrina:  哈哈好
Katrina: Haha, alright.
Katrina:  给AI提供了宝贵的素材
Katrina: Provided valuable material for AI.
Alice: 他好松啊这个爪
Alice: This claw is really loose.
Alice: 不行我还要这个我不信
Alice: No way, I want this one, I don't believe it.
Alice: 作罢
Alice: Giving up.
Alice: 不行
Alice: No way.
Alice: 不跟你玩了
Alice: Not playing with you anymore.
Alice: 不行我还要再试一次
Alice: No way, I want to try again.
Alice: 戒了
Alice: Quitting.
Alice: 多出来一个币
Alice: Got an extra coin.
Alice: 谁还有用
Alice: Who needs it?
Katrina:  我没了一个也用不了
Katrina: I'm out, can't use any.
Alice: 好臭
Alice: So gross.